hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to finding advice get
ready for awesomeness epic oh [ __ ]
off to a bad start oh don't make me cry
don't make me cry like poor Isaac yeah
don't know how I got out of that one oh
wait I can jump if I time this
correcting their butt cook nope yep oh
damn it woo
damn it hey yeah I did it that's awesome
I bet I can jump to this chest I can
that's so cool oh oh oh there we go okay
I thought it was gonna be stuck there
that's so cool that is so cool woah woah
woah woah woah woah woah yeah excitable
turd but that's the name of your actual
character is an excitable turd guy can't
be losing too much health I got it I
gotta be more gentle about everything
I'm getting a little too overzealous I
can't I can't die I will cry like a
little baby I will cry no cry no cry
whoa hey no no no no no no no I will
jump out of your way
Boosh
sorry trying to concentrate guys I'm
gonna concentrate not no god damn it not
again just die already
goodness gracious that guy was too tough
it's not power not not proper we need
some there goes my soul hearts or
whatever they were called I don't
remember damn it damn it damn me to him
me and my hubris what is that it triple
a battery tickle charge oh well oh oh
that's nice
oh but I don't know how to keep her
friends close Charlie's I don't know
what that means I don't know what I
ruled owes me excuse me sorry but I
guess I'm okay
oh god no whoo let's go baby
yes right lucky horseshoe I don't know
what that means for me
ooh I don't have enough for any of this
I guess I could get a bomb likes well
this is one bomb for five cents I don't
know which one would be bad or I go with
the horseshoe for good luck I guess I
could go in here probably not worth it
but here we go
oh it was worth it it was totally worth
it oh it was so worth it nice nice it
was so worth it okay so now that we got
that got that
I think I'm good yeah whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa three segments Larry over
here good god what are you what happened
to you what could have possibly ripped
out your spine like that Oh Oh he really
is three segments Larry but these guys
are all just on their bottom segment and
they have no chance in hell even though
we obviously are in hell yeah well you
little
wowyou corn-fed turds don't even try to
do that stop it
may you be pure in heart I don't know
what that card does some people probably
do but I do not figure it out as soon as
I get through this room what is this
teleport whoa that not what I I'd rather
have the jump thank you very much rather
half of a job that did not do me exactly
what I wanted it to do yeah thank you
I'll take the jump way comes cool if I
actually was able to give jump oh I'm
not gonna risk at what is that down
there some combat room oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh hey you are Larry senior babies Larry
double juniors you're the child of Larry
juniors I think you weirdos just give me
the money money money money thank you
and did okay there we go oh god no no
not like this not like this oh damn it
[ __ ] who the careful got to be careful
gotta be careful gotta be careful got to
be careful no no no no no yep okay more
more there's more oh god oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey whoa yeah this jump is
useful I like this jump this jumps the
best Oh God oh I got a kid that's right
I got to destroy like the piles of meat
that they're in for they resurrect I
forgot about that I think I think I've
seen these guys before I think I got one
two three and dead okay more yes okay
that went well
that one's surprisingly well and I'm
actually gonna I think I can I think the
Blackhearts you can fill up again so
there was another yeah there was
something else in here so if I did this
let me just we're up there we go grab
that oh I guess you can't nevermind that
was a lie okay so now I can move forward
sorry this has been very stressful I'm
really trying to hold on as best I can
and if I can just now what is the
question is what does this card do whoa
that's not what I want that's the
opposite of what I want I will keep all
of my health please thank you okay just
seems to be a normal room nothing
special oh whoa what yeah well wait what
oh god damn it he was gonna avoid me I
was gonna be fine I tried to jump out of
the way I ended up jumping into him so
boy hey boom baby
haha didn't end up in the secret room
but it sure did end up in your death
it's convenient for me you don't even
have a face
so that lost me my black heart that's
okay
didn't cost me my black spark you get
the way you guys shake very creepy very
not cool very not cool
okay come on come on c'mon c'mon just
die already die whoa whoa
okay don't know what you guys whoa
that's what you guys do jeez it's so
much I don't know guys there's so much I
don't know I don't know what you do
amnesia
oh I forgot the map okay go to hoof
speed up I'll take the luck I still
don't know what the luck does but yeah
I'll take the goat hoof why not
all right so I'm good let's do this come
on chub I've been seeing all your little
babies all day so I figured he might as
well be you
oh you take so much damage hey whoa hey
chubster what are you doing there what
happens if I kill your chubby babies huh
what are you gonna do he's sad well yeah
he's got something - an adorable slash
terrifying face whoo but doesn't look
like you're all that said oh he pooped
out a baby geese ah goddamn it
whoa whoa easy there buddy
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I got trapped in the corner
I'm sorry I forgot I can jump
whoa whoa Oh goddamn the baby I can't
let the baby get me I'm taking way too
much damage oh god damn it what the [ __ ]
I'm sorry the controls are just not good
for me like because I'm playing on a
keyboard oh god damn it no no no no no
no no don't like this I don't wanna cry
like a baby I don't wanna cry oh oh I
don't wanna cry like a baby oh god oh
god okay I jumped right into him why did
I join mintage up left it jumped
diagonal this so stupid guys you know
that stupid it's not my fault I was
doing fine I was doing fine I'm doing it
getting all the way to the end speed run
baby speed run baby I should get a key
oh yeah I should get a controller but
too late
damage reduction great good for me now I
got to stare at that ugly-ass face all
time
I lost my power-ups I lost my special I
had everything I could that was like one
of the easiest boss why did I die
why my rage grows it is indeed my rage
does grow thank you game for being oddly
pertinent to the situation that I am
screw you guys screw you guys screw you
I hate you oh this is so stupid
oh god it's not stupid I know it's my
fault I was doing Tara I don't know why
I did so bad I don't know why I should
have done so much better that was I
who's stupid like that I relied on the
jump and it just it didn't turn out well
and I wasn't doing good man I had that
in the bag and then I just lost it I had
it and I lost it
I grabbed onto it and then I let it go I
loved it and I kated know I had it and I
went away oh god this is not gonna end
well because I too many of these [ __ ]
good thing I pushed that bomb away from
where it was cuz that was the best
strategy in that situation I'm glad this
happened to me
oh [ __ ] these fires are getting bigger
if I don't kill them
so I better kill them with my face full
of tears they go well God maybe I should
have focused on the big guy because he
only puts out a certain number of flies
but um boom boom boom boom badoom boom I
might die hey I did it I'm such a badass
now I'm such a good player at this game
shot speed up magic 8-ball but my head
turned into a disco ball don't know why
I'm still trying to sing it's stupid mmm
what is that seriously what is on my
head I don't know the do-rag maybe oh
god why why why why why why why
wha hey hey there we go
Oh God sweet all right I got this
oh but oh I got a mega mean I didn't
know that was I thought it was a but I
was pretty sure that was but let's blow
this up cuz why now baby I got nothing
better to do with my laughs give me huh
boom okay now I got to find a way to get
to that key because it probably need it
for something in the future but not
immediately right now I had my jump it'd
be no problem
hello guys what you gonna do what's
gonna deal with all that ass well then
ass since I've demise did it wheel of
fortune
hell yeah boink oh I have no money well
this was absolutely not worth it to me
so I'm gonna go on my way with my do-rag
stupid screw you guys screw you guys
screw you guys yeah dime the fire nice
[ __ ] I can't afford any of that why
couldn't I have the incredible luck that
I had the last time then I play this
game that apparently was everyone was
amazed by I want to amaze everybody with
my skill if not my skill than other
parts of me that people would just be
amazed by that's not what you think it's
not we think not weaving let's do this
Oh little horn more like little douche
and beat you seven ways to Sunday little
horn we're like well I probably can't
not seven ways to Sunday that's it's
kind of bragging on Oliver
whoa oh damn it
why do you have to take so much damage
hoho he blew himself up baby he's such
an e what a stupid gift Oh 20 gram
damage up cool
not bad for me I'll take that thank you
moving right along I'm gonna make it
yeah uh okay think your mom have might
some of the disease your mom might have
the gout
why do they have to explode in blood why
do they have to try to [ __ ] I thought
there was like some period of damage
boost to this game but appears like
sometimes there is and sometimes there
is not like a little period of immunity
after you get hit no never again
what does what is this I don't know what
this does probably not good
Spyder [ __ ] Oh God not you not the one
I can't hit for some goddamn reason
there we go ah perfect
thank you for the key I needed it for
this so I can get my lucky foot yeah
luck up baby I don't know what that's
gonna do for I'm gonna go through here
not worth it problem Oh totally worth it
totes mix croats worth it good for me
now if I can only heal this things up
what did this red patch do again
my rage grows no never again
well I don't want to go oh I want to go
in here I can take it on one chest whoa
stuck in an endless loop I don't know
with them yeah
yeah okay those are gonna explode into
blood bags but diagonally see if I
actually knew and understood endless
nameless if I knew and understood these
things Oh God
$5 dollars worth $5 thank you oh dang
well that guy looks not fun
am i doing anything to that guy it
doesn't seem like I'm actually doing
anything oh that's right that's right he
does he's another one of the things that
does the thing there we go got him got
him gun oh come on with the key yeah
there we go okay everything's fine I
thought everything was bad but
everything it turns out to fine thank
you another key thank you all right
who's gonna be easy baby come on hit it
hit it hit it there we go Oh Hill over
there Hill over there oh man I mean
wanted that okay I still haven't used my
butt oh [ __ ] these guys [ __ ] these guys
[ __ ] these guys [ __ ] these guys
whoa oh I guess I just go past this guy
okay bye then
I'm gonna go to the boss now Bertie jr.
yeah I don't want to meet Gertie senior
cheese Oh God
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa none of that
whoa holy crap I don't know what that
did but it was awesome
no thank you well thank you Gertie
junior please don't
woo whoa god damn it
yep not today buddy boo not today buddy
boo not today buddy boo there we go
thank you for dying yeah that's another
one bites the dust another one that I'm
on my way to roid rage good more and
more Wow I am fast I didn't ho didn't
mean to go that fast
all right I'm halfway there I'm gonna
make it oh did my ding-dong fall off why
did my dingdong fall off what kind of
horrible thing happen to me oh boy a lot
of little shits
yeah man we're adorable little pieces of
poop Oh personified into a wonderful
chorus of Horrors and hell's wonderful
good for me alright
mysterious candy I don't know what that
means you okay
oh hello
okay I was just operating under the
assumption that was still gonna go and I
don't know why that's locked but it is
serious what is what is this what does
this do
I don't know
you better run you better run
whoa when this got me with that one okay
Oh God not these [ __ ] no no no no no
no no no no no I don't like this not
cool not cool not cool not cool like the
opposite of cool
it seems like some something I have is
causing me to be able to shrug off
damage which I like bombing run done
okay
Thank You Zanna all right um I didn't
get an item but i think i have a heart
waiting for me oh i didn't know i had a
key waiting for me okay good for me good
for me good for me not good for you good
for me that's right okay crotch you know
let me find out what's in here first
a little adorable shits nope not today
not today not today not today
got a double lock door here but good
thing I got extra keys god damn it I
keep miss under estimating how many hits
is gonna take to kill him
thinking oh I'm gonna kill him before he
gets to me nope wrong stupid a whole
markiplier there we go okay what's this
oh that was the wrong button you hear
hear get busy my brain baby huh tell me
more about how your life sucks but this
one nope also wrong and that wasn't
right either what good did that do me
why was this a double locked room
I thought double locked meant double
rewards really nothing nothing for that
even the whole room looks like a
treasure chest what a bunch of baloney
there's got to be like a something here
something right
or nothing or that was a big waste of
all my resources that I carefully Colet
these guys don't look fun they explode
for some reason explodey flies good nope
not doing that getting a lot of money
but I have nothing to spend the money on
blow whoa these guys don't look fun how
am I supposed to get to them I don't
think I am supposed oh I'm not supposed
to get to him okay poof please
hmm scary huh huh I got it baby
nice nice nice nice okay let's do this
hello mega fatty oh you so fast you got
blood shooting out of your face can I
die that did nothing whoa yeah nice whoa
don't suck me in
whoa whoa whoa whoa mega fatty can mega
move
I had no idea huh doesn't seem like
something that mega fatty would be
capable of did you just fart crap did
you just shout out all that cuz if so
gross
well mega fatty you've got some powers
that I can't understand my mind simply
cannot comprehend the wonders of your
world
Oh mega fatty don't exploded mega fatty
gone bye-bye
dog food yay that's all I have deep I
literally have to scavenge for
everything oh no I didn't see the door
damn it I didn't see the special door
I'm sorry guys I'm sister failure I can
make this I can do this I can get all
the way I can go all the way
Oh turn matter Tarson yeah what are you
oh you oh god what are you oh god you're
like a mini boss you're a mini boss you
know you turn into those little [ __ ]
uh damn it yeah I always just lose
health no matter what no matter what I
do
damn it all god it's the vagina man oh
god it's the vagina man with the weird
heads the weird parasitic head vagina
buddies I will admit this game is super
fun like it is fun it may not seem like
I'm having tons of fun but I'm just
really concentrating right now trying
not to die but it is a very fun game
I will readily admit super fun and the
replayability is amazing in the game
please tell me one of these poops
contain a heart spider but massive
enemies slow down Plus damage sounds
cool to me better than the mega bean
maybe we can slow the enemy down that
might also be working to my advantage
okay but I only have two hearts oh [ __ ]
oh god damn it why why don't kill me I
will so slow you down uh God the enemies
like the variety of enemies that they
have in this game is really cool I could
have got I could have handled this I
just didn't know the enemies that was
another problem that I don't know the
enemies when I come across them so that
when I find them it often is a bit of a
crapshoot of whether at oh yes please
thank you goodbye
this C 48-hour energy I don't know what
the battery is for I don't know yeah
whatever I probably should have spent
for the card good enough
oh god
these [ __ ] bugs bugs bugs bugs bugs
bugs but oh really no I'm gonna die it's
gonna be so sad luck up okay what's with
the laughing whoa whoa hello lady are
you doing okay fun times thank you good
enough oh god I forgot damn it out damn
it oh damn it oh damn damn damn damn all
right let's try this boss with one and a
half hearts Oh mom's true 2.0 okay so
maybe I'll know a bit of what he's gonna
do oh look at that
none for you none for you one for you
and me
oh that I forgot monstro can do that
[ __ ] I'm lucky I shrug off damage
would be awesome if I could actually hit
monstro here because seems to be a lot
of things getting in my goddamn way Oh
frickin Lakha oh no god it's not
unexpected but I was killed by a fly oh
man I this game is hard this game is
hard I'm not even playing on hard mode
although I am bad at the game so that's
all for now I'll pick it up again if you
guys really want to let me know let me
know if you really want to see more of
the game because I do enjoy playing it
it's just I'm not very bad at this game
I don't know how to coordinate what I do
it's often very difficult so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the end of days more cool videos that
I've done in the past and all the sorts
of games that I played I've got over
2,000 videos tons of stuff there's bound
to be some of that you haven't seen I'll
put some random videos in the
description so thank you again everybody
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye